y un parto por cesárea generalmente
conocido como cesárea es un
procedimiento quirúrgico en que se
realizan incisiones en el abdomen y
útero de una mujer para dar a luz un
bebé algunas cesáreas se planifican sin
embargo a menudo a la necesidad del
procedimiento se torna evidente después
del inicio del trabajo de parto cuando
las condiciones anormales hacen que un
parto natural no sea seguro para la
madre o su bebé las indicaciones comunes
para el parto por cesárea incluyen
distocia placenta previa y sufrimiento
fetal la distancia o trabajo de parto no
progresivo prolongado puede producirse
cuando la cabeza del bebé no cabe por el
canal del parto o su cuerpo se encuentra
en una posición desfavorable como por
ejemplo cuando está perpendicular al
canal del parto o de nalgas como lo es
la posición de nalgas la placenta previa
se presenta cuando la placenta se
encuentra en una posición baja y
obstruye de manera parcial o por
completo la abertura cervical el
sufrimiento fetal se produce cuando la
salud del bebé se encuentra en peligro
inminente por lo general debido al flujo
insuficiente de sangre a través de la
placenta o el cordón
y el sufrimiento fetal puede producirse
cuando la placenta se separa de la pared
del útero antes del parto o el cordón
umbilical se comprime o estrangula otras
condiciones que pueden requerir un parto
por cesárea incluyen nacimientos
múltiples tumores grandes del útero
herpes genital u otras infecciones o
problemas médicos tales como la
hipertensión o la diabetes no controlada
el médico puede utilizar el trazo nido y
un monitor cardíaco fetal que lo
ayudarán a decidir si el bebé nacerá o
no por cesárea cuando sea necesario
realizar un parto por cesárea se la
preparará para una cirugía si aún no se
le ha colocado se le colocará una vía
endovenosa y se le insertará un catéter
en la vejiga para drenar la orina
en la sala de operaciones se le
anestesiar a en la mayoría de los casos
se administra una anestesia peridural
para adormecer la parte inferior del
cuerpo sin embargo algunas veces se
utilizará anestesia general
el médico comenzará realizando una
incisión en el abdomen será una incisión
vertical justo debajo del ombligo hasta
la parte superior del hueso púbico o con
mayor frecuencia una incisión horizontal
en forma transversal y justo por encima
del hueso púbico a esta incisión en
general se la denomina incisión de
bikini luego el médico realizará una
segunda incisión en la parte inferior
del útero una vez que se abre el útero
su médico romperá la bolsa amniótica si
aún está intacta el bebé nacerá el
tiempo que transcurre desde la incisión
abdominal inicial hasta el nacimiento es
por lo general de cinco minutos
luego el médico pensará y cortará el
cordón umbilical
extraerá cuidadosamente la placenta y
saturará bien el útero y el abdomen
generalmente esto dura alrededor de 45
minutos por lo general la estadía en el
hospital después de un parto por cesárea
es de 3 a 5 días durante este tiempo se
le recomendará que am amante duerma
cuando el bebé duerme y se levante de la
cama a menudo aunque la mayoría de las
pacientes pueden ocuparse de su bebé
recién nacido después del procedimiento
la recuperación completa puede tardar
entre 6 y 8 semanas la cicatriz se irá
aclarando a medida que sane